[Music]
all right let's go out to Denver
Colorado and talk to the great and
wonderful Julie hey Julie what's
up hi John thanks for taking my call of
course thanks for calling what's up how
can I help okay so I have what seems
like a silly question but it's an
important one to me um in my last couple
of years I'm not keeping friends or I'm
not making new friends I had like three
core friends through the 20s and then
you know we got married and had children
and stuff and then I actually lost one
of my friends a few months
ago and I don't know if it's just a
season of life where people don't want
new
friendships I feel like I'm really
putting myself out there and
trying uh and I just I don't know I
don't know if adults are too busy to
have friends or if we're just done with
that time so I would say this is the
least silly question that you could
possibly
ask well I listen to your show and
there's much deeper question yeah but
this is I think one of the chief like in
150 years when they're sifting through
the rubble this will be the story they
told about how they created the most
Magic incredible civilization and people
died of loneliness right underneath it
right and they went M they went they
went Stone insane which is what our
culture I mean look around we've gone
crazy um and you can say it's because of
politics because the way people believe
and on and on and on and on and
businesses and black rock and blah
conspiracy all that stuff sure none of
that happens on a bed of connected human
interaction it just doesn't on deep
powerful friendships it just doesn't and
so so but here we are so I think what
you're asking is one of the most
profound questions of our age and um oh
thank you you're experiencing it in real
time and I also don't want to blow by
like so I think we've created the
loneliest generation in human history
and um that sounds cool like on a bumper
sticker it doesn't sound cool when
you're Julie in Denver and you you live
in Denver because it's a young hit place
where everybody's like hey let's go hang
out and then nobody wants to hang out
and then I also don't want to blow
by like you're sitting in some deep
grief right now what happened to your
friend well I actually live in one of
the ski towns of Colorado oh so it's
fight or flight they're all there and
then they're all gone yeah yeah well and
they're all like uber rich and I don't
know if I just come across as not
wealthy I don't know like I rub them
that like I can't figure it out
um so I first of all I am married and
you know we've been mostly happily
married for 13 years and we have a
seveny
old and how old are you I'm 43 oh you're
in my
boat yeah I'm in the you have a young
kid but you're 10 years older than most
of your young kids parents I am I am and
I look like a mom and I look like I
don't know a poor mom a little bit worn
you're ridiculous Julie that's
ridiculous okay so back to your question
um so I have core three friends that
were like my lifelong buddies and we did
all our 20s
together and then one of my friends uh
got sick about two years ago
and just went really quickly she had
actually three different
craniotomies and the last one was I
believe in March and she just she didn't
recover yeah and and she she
died what was her
name well her name was
Kendra and probably her husband or
family uh listens to your show ah okay
she was very loved yeah she sounds
amazing um she was amazing yeah my my
hope is
um when my time comes my
friends will say like man I lost I lost
a an arm and a leg when that guy like
that's that's I mean what more can you
say about somebody family is supposed to
talk good about you but your friends
that's a different level that's that's
she's amazing I think so um and I don't
know what to do with that like I don't
know how to take her out of my phone and
I keep wanting to like call and don't
don't so I I try to make connections
like at school pickup and hold on hold
on Don't Blow by that that's two
different things yeah I'm going to tell
you something crazy and people might
think I'm nuts but call and leave her a
voicemail
sometime well I think her husband would
think that's a little nuts but he can
call you and you can say I'm a little
bit nuts right
now right you're right or write her a
letter and tell her about all the things
that she's
missing and don't send it true but but
the
the I think there's this pressure to
just all everybody respond in a certain
way and some people respond by shutting
down and some people respond by they
keep picking up their phone keep picking
up their phone and keep picking up their
phone and some people talk to people
inside their own minds and and you know
when they're driving down the road they
don't say actual words but inside
they're having a conversation with
somebody that they've lost and so I
don't have any problem with with making
the call I don't have any problem with
shooting a text message I don't have any
problem with
um uh you know it's it's it's when it
becomes a Hillary Swank movie and so
somebody sends a text back that we're
like okay now we're no problem but no I
I I think I think your grief is going to
be what your grief is and then layered
on top of that is that
awkward I promise you you feel more out
of Step than you are in
reality yeah that might be true you're
not an ugly duckling and you're not
you're not out of community with the
people you live with and all all those
things in fact they would probably love
to have somebody with actual wisdom in
in some of their conversations
yeah I would hope but I try like I try
and I'm like oh well that was a
flop give me an example of a
flop so we started a new school um for
our daughter this year and I went to the
parent you know get to know the teachers
thing and I really made an effort of
like reaching out to new families that
said they were new to the area and I
gave out my phone number number and said
hey if you need a contact here you know
I'm available we can I can tell you
about some of the kid programs around
town um and I just tried and they looked
at me like well we don't really want
your help and why are you talking to us
is how it felt when I walked away and I
was like well I don't know and so what
you felt was vulnerability you did not
feel
reality I don't think correct
and everybody in the new school is
trying to get used to the air and is our
kid going to be safe and who's this
teacher and who's this room who's this
principal and so it's kind of like when
back in like college a buddy of mine
would would say I have one friend in
particular who went up to this beautiful
woman in in like the middle of like
accounting and was like hey would you
like to go out and it's like time and
place man like this isn't the moment
right and so right I think the next step
which is going to be this is you feeling
that vulnerability those those social
anxiety alarms and you going game on and
you go straight into them but the next
step is you reach out to them and invite
them over with their kid over to
play right right and I felt like I was
doing it in an appropriate manner like I
know I'm being was talking to people I
wasn't like cornering them and not
letting them free from the playground
area yeah no no I totally get that
and there's just so many Dynamics there
but there's something else at your
kitchen table that humanizes everything
and especially I can tell you'd be the
person and be like well I'm the old
seven-year-old mom and everyone would
laugh they go no you're not and then
that B that that bullet is out of the
gun it's out of the chamber now right
now we're friends right and now I can
ask you hey I've been married seven
years is this normal and you can go no
it's not normal or yeah it's totally
normal cuz I'm I'm 13 years down the
road so I
it's it comes back to this core issue
that I hear over and over and I'm going
to be honest with you I experience it
myself I am an awkward friend and I wish
that I wasn't and I don't mean to be but
I'm just awkward and my friends who I've
known for 30 years they know yeah delone
just stands over there by himself at
concerts it's so weird and delone just
thinks that joke is hilarious and it is
for sure not I at all not even a little
bit or D just leaves he just goes to the
bathroom and he goes home and he didn't
tell us he was leaving and I didn't even
think about it cuz we were having a
great conversation I'm just going to go
ahead and go home and so they know that
but new friends don't and so I'll tell
you there's only one path forward oh let
me let me before I tell you the path
what I've come to realize is me and
everybody I talk to has this core sense
and you're expressing it in a really in
a funny way but there's some truth to
it you almost almost feel middle school
again
braces do I look right are these the
right
jeans and it it's this core sense of
what happened to my friends and that's
what our bodies do when we are
alone and to answer your original
question I think the hardest part of
turning 35 was realizing that the
friendships I had that were so
meaningful and deep and Powerful in my
wedding in my 20s like that guy got
divorced and this guy took another job
this guy had two kids and this guy had
no kids and we just kind of faded out
and there is no manual for 35 and 45y
Old Friends it doesn't exist right and
so the only thing I've seen that works
is just to go be
weird and just invite people over and
invite people over and we in our house
we've done it and we've done it again
then we've done it again and then boom
we ended up with a couple of really
close
friends okay but it but it's as simple
as knowing in our core you and me folks
in our situation who moved in new
communities at our age with younger
kids we're pretty cool we're good you
know what I mean like sure we got some
miles on US is that what you said got
some weather on us or whatever you said
sure I'm BN a little worn you're worn
it's so ridiculous like you're a
car we tried um you know soccer so this
is new and I just remember sitting on
the field being like oh man this is
boring I don't want to be here yes but I
thought oh I'll talk to some of the moms
and you know families around and I just
stood there and I'm like okay no one
wants to like make connection they they
don't yes correct and that is very very
true until somebody
does okay until somebody does and I I I
mean the only other thing that I've seen
effective and this has been way more my
wife than me is to get involved in
community groups like my wife's a writer
so she gets involved she has a group of
writers and they meet once a month or a
group of women who are coach
professionals and she hangs out with
them um she has a group from our church
and they get together pretty regularly
so um but it was group- based and we all
it's it's everyone shows up to this
thing and we all have this one common
interest in common can we go from there
because people show up to soccer games
you know this just by watching them
there's those parents who show up as
this is like a pre-ol workout program
and then there's the scholarship Roi
parents and then there's the um like
court ordered parents and then there's
the kid just running around in circles
looking for his gain controler out in
the middle of the field parents I mean
it's they're all everyone goes to soccer
but it's for a thousand different
reasons everybody shows up to Jiu-Jitsu
for one reason everybody shows up to
horseback riding for one reason and so
that's where I think you can get
involved in some in some groups and that
sounds insane when you're the parent of
a seven-year-old cuz I am one too like I
don't
the thought of having the time to go get
involved in a group is
madness yeah and we we also have our own
business so my husband and I our
conversations are typically around our
business or just life in general and so
I was looking for more of like an outlet
of I mean I love my husband and he needs
me to have a girlfriend in life
too so maybe a group
thing the way you said that was
incredible
and I know what you meant but you said
that
awesome thanks Ben have a good life I
just want some more friends like the way
you said it was like I love my husband
and he wants a girlfriend and I had to
stop for a second you said he wants you
to have no I'm sorry he wants you to
have some other friend to have like a
someone that I can go do something with
it's a very different call now there you
go there you go yes yeah right very
different I know grammar matters no he
does not want a girlfriend what's your
uh what's your
business uh we have like a mobile uh
Tire
Service okay this is going to sound nuts
and maybe you don't want to hang out
with Tire folks but is there I mean
again I'm stretching here but is there
some sort of barbecue that your husband
throws at his house for families that
are in small businesses or in Mobile
businesses or some kind of something
that picks up with whatever um is there
a group of
moms of seven-year olds that you can
have over to your house and only three
are going to show up and one of them is
going to be so weird and then the other
two are going to be kind of normal but
they're not going to talk because of
over there and
like let me say
this the Friendship thing is not hard
because you're a bad person the
Friendship thing is not hard because
you're not worth being a friend or
nobody wants to be friends with
you I think the friendship that thing is
hard because we don't have a skill set
we don't have a road map none of us were
prepared for being 30 or 35 or 40 and
realizing all of our friends had moved
or taken jobs or had kids or gotten
married or
whatever we are all by ourself and then
our body starts screaming at us
something as simple as and you know Ben
and I talked about this we talked about
this on this very show about there's
something about getting together and
playing music with some friends and
these guys are co-workers and
a couple of these guys I've shared a
couple of different years which means we
were in the same tiny little room
practicing for months on end and then we
go have this like common Mission and
each of us like screw up in our own
little way on stage and we all kind of
laugh and each of us like hit something
out of the park on stage it ends up
being like a group of guys that I really
respect and that I really like hanging
out with and that I really like laughing
with and then I really like so natural
friendships develop out of that that
normally wouldn't have been there
because we didn't have that common
Mission so the two PA again to wrap it
up the two paths forward go be weird go
invite people to your house and
consciously say I'm not going to make
this thing spotless this isn't a
Southern Living magazine ad this is my
friends I'm going to have some friends
over and there will be some awkward
interactions and then there's going to
be one or two magic ones and then the
second thing is is start seeking in your
local community to join some groups and
I know it's harder the more rural you
get that's harder the busier you get but
let's put that on the calendar hey honey
I'm going to step away from family
business for two hours a week to go do
reading at the library with some friends
or go to the knitting club or the
whatever club and he's going to say I'm
going to go to the fishing club or to
the ski shooting club or whatever y'all
do um and begin to just put yourselves
out there it will continue to be weird
because you have you're lacking skills
and the people you're trying to connect
with have no skills either so it's a
bunch of kids who have never seen a
basketball game in their life and
somebody handed them a ball and two
hoops and they said play basketball and
they're hitting each other in the head
with the ball kicking it bouncing off
each other's face I mean it's just a mad
house until y'all slowly get the Rhythm
and one guy's like I think you dribble
and the other gu like I think you shoot
and so keep at it my promise is there is
friends out there there are adults
desperate for wise funny cool people
like you small business owners with
seven-year-olds trying to figure out
phones and dating and all that weird
stuff man they're out there I promise
just keep showing up and just keep
showing up and stop that tick or tape
that story that runs underneath your
life that says you're not worth having
friends that story that keeps going and
going that says you don't have any
friends because nobody likes you you
don't have any friends because you're
not worthy of being liked you don't have
any friends because because because cut
that nonsense out because it's not true
it's just simply not
true